[Music]
I was I was terrified because and fear
isn't something I deal with regularly
when it comes to acting because if you
get cast you're the part and I think
well they picked me I'm good it's the
easy way not to get self-deprecating or
lose confidence but there's a difference
here we're not just acting a script
we're playing characters that have
existed in another medium people have
seen Willy before they've seen me it's
different
so my subversion to deflect that lack of
confidence it didn't work because there
there was a dude already there was an
image there was a he exists so I was
scared because I'm quite large compared
to the character in the comic in the way
he's drawn and I was I was scared I was
like what what if people think oh that's
not right that's not how he looked
because that's what I hear and a lot of
from a lot of comic book fans it's not
like the comic but the writers told me
that a real and honest translation would
be different than one medium because in
real life for somebody to be able to
survive with an uncompromising idea to
not partake in violence but still be
perceived as someone deadly they have to
look a certain way so they put the
cornrows on and they dressed me in the
uniform and everything and that was
Willy and there came my confidence you
know oh yeah in the toothpick too
straight out of the comic you know but
my confidence came from the writers
reassuring me that it's not just about
looking like the comics it's about
bringing them to life know that you got
it all right there yeah yeah no legit I
was really excited about the fact that
when when you see Chico Chico has
special moments you know like you don't
know why he's acting that way but you
just know that he saw he's acting that
way and in the show I love that they go
really into the origins of every
character so like the comic book is
really limited you know the writer has
this amount of pages to tell the story
now that we're filming an episode we
have a lot a lot to say and a lot to
show so I was really excited I was I was
I was also like maybe not terrified but
I was I was nervous man I was nervous
because I because also like me and Chico
the resemblance is not that much you
know but but I had an opportunity to
give life to this to this guy and and
and just reading what he did and and
knowing that in the show I was gonna
have more opportunities to tell a story
of how he is the way he is I think it's
like if it's not a one-dimensional
villain man that would be so boring you
know like just a bad guy that does bad
things because he likes to be bad
no this is a human being that had a life
that turned him into what he is and he's
a killer man he's been doing it since
he's like 7 years old and even though
it's heartbreaking it's really exciting
to go into the shoes of that guy and
understand his mind
Chico's power for me is his mind he he
knows how to fight he knows how to move
he knows how to you know how to pass
every class but the mind that like the
mind said the the mind power that he has
was I one step ahead of everybody in in
Kings I mean in that that is such a good
Power Man you know for me I think if it
was any other project I would have been
absolutely terrified to the point of
probably not even wanting the part
because because the character of Billy
is so different from myself you know
I've never I've always had long hair you
know this is the shortest my hair has
ever been I know I have the mohawk in
the show and then I shaved it off but
you know to go and change yourself that
much you know I would have felt like a
clown up there the bad kind of clown
that none of us wants to be if it was
just a show where oh we'll just have him
say this this weekend you know we'll do
that you know but since everything was
so perfectly curated and the and the
message is so important and and people
can really relate to it that I think I
was excited and I knew that with the
support of the creative team that I
could that I could do it for sure
one two or three hey by five yeah
five you know I feel like it's not only
the mid-season finale it's a it's a
conclusion like a conclusion of events
that had to happen you know you're gonna
get to see characters that you've been
waiting for to come together it either
in a fight or in a relationship or in a
in a lie together you know it's it's
such a conclusion of events and it and
after that episode nothing is never
gonna be the same for the TV show and
for every other of the characters so I
think it's like the you know like like
the writers have been leaving some seats
episode by episode and you want
characters to come together either in a
fight or either in a relationship or
either in a compromise or a secret and
and suddenly it explodes in front of
their face and nothing is ever gonna be
the same and I think it's such a good
conclusion of events man and it's gonna
change the story forever now yeah I
concur yeah I think you know it's a big
episode for for all of the characters in
in defining who they are and and who
they're gonna be coming forward you know
what they have and and and really a lot
of them coming together as uh seeing
them as a family for the first time and
there was that when we five is halfway
through when we started filming you know
the fifth episode of filming and I
really noticed us all starting to become
you know we all really like each other
from the beginning but but you know just
that book type of bonding does does
something to you so it means something
to me more than just the episode is a
defining point in my in our relationship
even though we respect each other and we
love each other after that episode
it was just you know like yeah yeah yeah
and just a super special episode and
it's and it's so true to the comic book
that that it was one of the most high
stakes because we wanted to get it right
we really wanted to get it right yeah
and so we just everyone was firing on
also
unders yeah y'all gonna have to check
that out
Hogwarts for assassins yeah that's
Russia with Game of Thrones stakes yes
you know the stakes are real guys the
danger is real
and so it's a unique show it's original
and I really really it's not like I want
to like oversell it but I haven't seen
anything like that on TV I can't tell
you what's similar to deadly class which
is why we have to use so many different
shows to describe it you said Hogwarts
for assassins Dave of throwing sticks
it's the good parts of a lot of
different things which means it's this
amalgam which also means it's nothing
like the pieces that it uses boom get it
yeah